please Department
and we'll show you the owner Hannah in a
second
yeah we'll show it to you
[Applause]
because right now under delayed
being active illnesses
Varys
which I think what we're gonna tell you
right now because I mean you're not I
don't think you're acting you know
absolutely right
[Music]
Sammy Nikolaev was five months old when
Sacramento County's Child Protective
Services seized him from his parents
what they done was basically kidnapped
our child with the help of police it all
started with a trip to the hospital
Sammy had flu symptoms and his parents
wanted urgent treatment you went to the
hospital and then they told us that he
has the flu and that's when it started
Sammy was born with a heart murmur but
doctors told his parents to wait until
Sammy was older and stronger before
considering surgery that's why they were
surprised when doctors at the hospital
recommended immediate surgery so they
wanted a second opinion and they they
were coming up basically with some
random stuff oh we need to do this
buying another thing just to keep us
there they said you could go we'll keep
the baby so where is our parents choice
feeling increasingly trapped and
desperate and they're removed Sammy from
the hospital and took him directly to
Kaiser for a second opinion I just was
scared I did not know what to do so I
packed him I packed all my stuff and we
walked out when we had to Kaiser
basically it's the whole different thing
down there we came there and they're
like why would you want to check him the
baby looks fine and police came there
which they were called by I guess CPS
and they felt kind of I guess stupid and
stuff at first cuz they they came there
all aggressive the police left and the
doctors discharged Sammy it was the next
day but CPS workers showed up at her
front door they told me that the CPS
needs to see our son and I asked him
with me kind of show me the warrant and
she told me you have to open the door
one way the police when she called me I
heard all the knocking on the door and
stuff they were they were basically
breaking the door down I was scared
I did not know what to do as a matter I
did not want them to take him and do any
treatments or thought you know
like saying really that he really needs
dead thanks to this footage from the
camera Anna set up the raid on the knick
alliance made national news and prompted
a statewide audit of California's Child
Protective Services agencies a lot of
parental concern about our agency and
the reputation of the agency is based on
sensationalism and misunderstanding of
what we do
sherry Heller is head of Sacramento
County's Health and Human Services the
agency that oversees CPS she says
there's more to this story than meets
the eye but she can't and won't say
exactly what that is
I regret that I'm not able to answer
questions about specific cases because
both federal health care law and the
State of California's child welfare law
make it illegal for government agencies
involved in this kind of a case to talk
about anything that's in the case record
unless the court allows it and anyone
can petition the court we did file a
petition to open court records for this
case almost two months later there still
hasn't been a ruling and the records
remained sealed the secrecy by which CPS
operates is a massive problem because
when you when you have secrecy and
unchecked power you have a recipe for
corruption and abuse State Assemblyman
Tim Donnelly spearheaded the audit in
California after writing a letter to
Sherri Heller requesting more
information in the wake of the Nikolaev
raid and she basically wrote me back and
said we don't answer to Assemblyman we
don't answer the state legislature so in
between the lines what I heard was we
answer to no one the law is clear that
it's appropriate to act without a court
warrant if children are in imminent
danger of physical harm if you are given
the task of protecting children that's a
high bar and there's a great
responsibility that comes with that and
therefore I think that it's vital that
this agency no longer cloaked themselves
in secrecy Deana Hardwick found herself
and her children Meyer
in the secretive system when a social
worker removed her six and nine year old
daughters from her custody social
workers were brought in to investigate a
claim against her ex-husband that was
later found to be unsubstantiated
but once CPS enters your life it's often
hard to get them out my youngest
daughter ran into me during one of the
visits and said that she wasn't a let
them go home with me that night I asked
the social worker is it true and she
said it's what true and I said are you
not gonna let my kids go home with me
tonight and she said I told him if they
didn't visit with their dad the judge is
gonna put him in a home
Deanna and her children were shaken by
the social workers threat to put them in
a home but Deanna resolved to keep her
head down and her mouth shut hopeful
that her dealings with CPS were almost
over but the next day in court things
took a turn for the worse instead of her
admitting that she made the threat she
blamed the threat on me and the judge
believed her and she proceeded to build
a false claims and a false case against
me she sat me down and said basically
what I needed to do was to submit to her
I would never see my kids again
Deanna refused to submit and sign a
document corroborating the social
worker's version of events
she lost her court case and lost custody
of her children but things finally
turned around when she successfully sued
Orange County CPS and the social workers
who had targeted her the court records
are sealed but an unsuccessful appeal
mounted by CPS reveals that the jury
found social workers had lied falsified
evidence and suppressed exculpatory
evidence and done so with malice the
jury awarded Deanna 4.9 million dollars
because of interest and attorneys fees
Orange County ended up spending almost
11 million dollars on the case and six
and a half years later
Deanna regained partial custody of her
daughters but she says the damage can
never be undone it's a very painful
subject for everybody
I just can't help but always feel that
there's a disconnect between my children
and I the system is set up in a way that
it's encouraged to remove children from
the protective parent because it
generates a lot of funding funding is
available when a child is placed in a
foster home with strangers many critics
of CPS say that the funding incentivizes
the agency to just put more children
into the system and in a deposition
Orange County CPS director Michael Riley
seems to partly confirm this let's say
that you spend $10 a year
so therefore for the following year your
base now would be $10 you don't use your
whole ten dollars in one year the state
will take away for next year the unused
balance yes and that lowers your base
and all of that is still tied to the
number of children being brought into
Orange would this tied to the number of
children we have in a foster care system
or in do it as a part of that a public
information officer for Orange County
CPS told us that this deposition video
we included presents an inadequate
answer to a very complex question and
that their goal is to keep families and
children together in the wake of the
baby Sammy incident the nikolayeva
Deanne Hardwick and many other parents
who say they were victimized by CPS
gathered at the State Capitol to demand
serious scrutiny of this often secretive
organization registered nurse mother of
three and strong support of audit I'm
from San Diego California I have
witnessed ten years of abuse by CPS
please we're asking you look into this
agency lawmakers heard their voices and
voted overwhelmingly to allow the audit
to proceed most of us in this field are
eager for the public to understand what
happened and why it is a source of great
dismay to us when we're accused of
hiding behind the confidentiality law
once the American people are able to be
made aware that this is going on
I think that that will be a real step
forward toward making sure that there's
accountability and that the agency is
ultimately working towards keeping
families together rather than separating
right now we're coming back to a normal
life
and I hope it's gonna be everything like
ending soon here so we're gonna have our
lives back like they've been put forth
right
[Music]
you